[Music]
for your son's sixth birthday you've
promised to get him the cutest creature
in creation the cuddly it's hard to
believe that it's a cousin of the
terrifying Dudley or the hideous fugly
they're all members of the Woodley
species and the process of adopting them
is deeply peculiar it takes 100 eggs to
make a single animal in genus Woodley
when 100 eggs are placed together in an
incubator they undergo egg fusion and
combine in the following way blue and
purple combined to make red eggs red and
blue combined to make purple eggs and
red and purple combine to make blue eggs
the most plentiful eggs pair up first
and if two piles are even an egg comes
from one of them at random they keep
combining until there's just one left if
the final egg is blue a cutley hatches
out of it purple eggs give you Dudley's
and red eggs give you Fudd Lee's the
incubator currently has 99 eggs in it 23
are blue
33 are purple and 43 are red you can
begin the process of egg fusion by
adding an egg of any color to the room
when all the eggs have combined into a
single egg the creature that hatches
will bond with you on site which is why
getting a cuddley is so important after
all you made a promise to your son which
color eggs should you add to the
incubator to get a cuddly
it's easy to get mixed up with all the
cuddlies Dudley's and Fudd Lee's coming
from different colored eggs
if we ignore how many total eggs of each
color there are and just look at the
process of egg fusion we might notice
something that will make this problem
simpler when two eggs fuse the number of
eggs of each of those colors decreases
by one and the number of the third color
increases by one that means they all
change parity or evenness and oddness at
the same time right now all three piles
are odd but you get to add an egg to one
color which means that it'll be even and
the other two will be odd whichever
color you choose will always be the
opposite parity of the other two piles
odd when they're even and even when
they're odd since every egg fusion flips
each Pyles parity simultaneously we want
to end with one blue zero purple and
zero red x or odd even even that means
we want the blue egg pile to be the
opposite parity of the other two piles
at the start as well so you add a blue
egg into the room and 99 egg fusions
later only a single blue egg remains the
cuddley that hatches is sure to make
your six-year-old
as happy as can be just be sure to
follow the shopkeepers warning and never
feed it after midnight
you've managed to procure a cuddley but
can you use that same cunning to win a
wizard duel test your wand and your wits
with this riddle
[Music]